هاتفي يرن دون توقف ،
أتلقى مكالمات بلا توقف من
الأفغان العاديين الذين يخافون بشدة ممن
يبذلون قصارى جهدهم للخروج من
البلاد لتسوية
أوراقهم والذين يريدون إجابات يريدون الوضوح
ممن عملوا مع أشخاص آخرين.
المنظمات الحكومية يقولون إنهم لا يستطيعون حتى
إقناع الناس بالرد على الهاتف
وهم خائفون للغاية لدرجة أنهم
مرعوبون تمامًا وأريد أن أريكم
مقطعًا صغيرًا من امرأة تحدثنا إليها في
وقت سابق من هذا الصباح كانت تعمل في مجموعة
متنوعة  عدد المنظمات الدولية
بما في ذلك بعض
المنظمات الأمريكية ، إنها تخشى الآن على
حياتها لدرجة أنها تختبئ لدرجة أنها
لم ترغب في إظهار وجهها ولكن
استمع إلى ما قالت
إنه ليس من السهل على أي شخص أن يعمل
الكثير من المنظمات الدولية التي
لديها
أكثر من 10 سنوات من الخبرة في العمل
مع الدولية والآن لم
يساعدني أحد منهم في
إرسال رسائل بريد إلكتروني إلى
المنظمات المختلفة التي أعمل معك ولكن
لا
يوجد رد الآن  أنت غاضب ، لا أنا لست غاضبًا ، لكن بصفتي
شخصًا عمل معهم
الآن ، فأنا بحاجة إلى دعمهم
، فليس من العدل
أن تبدو عاطفيًا جدًا أيضًا ، نعم
لأنني أفكر في مستقبلي
بناتي ماذا سيحدث لهن إذا
اقتلني
ابنتان بدون أم ،
لا يمكنني حتى أن أبدأ في شرح
وجع القلب كصحفي أمريكي
يجلس وينظر إلى تلك المرأة في
عينها
بينما الدموع تنهمر على وجهها
كانت تقول أنني حلمت بمستقبل
أفضل لبناتي  وقد تم
سلبها مني في لحظة واحدة وهي
تطلب المساعدة بشدة مثل
العديد من الآخرين الذين يخافون بشدة
في هذه اللحظة غير المؤكدة